let's talk about this right here check
this out so this is one of the replies
to this this this tweet from felicia
sanmez who said the dhs and doj are
announcing a joint operation center to
investigate violent left-wing civil
unrest trump says
he this is a screen grab with a hundred
and two point seven
thousand retweets oh boy i wanna make
sure you can see it right there
102.7 k he says
the history of nazis holding rallies in
left-wing areas of weimar germany
instigating street fights and then
telling the press that only they could
save germany from the violent communists
seems like an important thing for people
to be studying right now
wow is that a gross mischaracterization
of what's happening now
and what happened back then do you know
where antifa
comes from tell me tim communist german
i'm sorry from weimar germany
it was the communist uh the german
communist party
anti-fascist action or whatever it is so
what's really been going on and we've
talked about i've talked about quite a
bit
going back to uh like the battle of
berkeley several years ago
the far left is organizing extreme
uh they're targeting peaceful rallies
and a lot of people criticize these
trump supporters for going to left-wing
areas and holding rallies
they didn't start any violence when in
berkeley for instance a bunch of trump
supporters went to the free speech plaza
or whatever
because it was historical berkeley you
know uh 1970s
and then antifa showed up and started
beating and attacking people throwing
explosives pulling out knives
improvised explosives and things like
that and i'm like okay
you no one made you attack these people
like you didn't have to do that
they decided to do it anyway and now
they're claiming it's the trump
supporters who are bad here
but the important factor the important
difference
who which which faction is going around
demanding people salute them
with that with with their arm
outstretched in front of them
probably the right wingers their nazis
the the who who's got their right arm
straight out in front of them and demand
other people are doing it right now
i get it the only difference between the
not the nazi's salute and what black
lives matter is doing is they make a
fist that's right i was gonna say you
see that there's a huge difference
because their fist is closed
ah it's not straight ahead of them and
i'm not even gonna imitate that
so we've seen the photos and videos they
go to diners they harass and attack
people
and then you get one trump rally
one in portland okay where they drove
their trucks through
and then here it is a hundred thousand
retweets i knew this was gonna happen
that's why i think you know cernovich
said stay home yep
make money and go vote absolutely my
thing is
speak up and we we talked about this a
few weeks ago where i was saying
you know defense like like old ladies
defending a statue is better
optics and everything yeah but speaking
up is the most important thing
in your workplace and i think it's i
don't know if staying home is the right
answer i
don't know what the right answer is but
i'll tell you this you drive your car
with a trump flag
and they will claim that militias are
invading cities i saw today somebody
compare it to isis
the trucks that drive through iraq with
isis flags yeah they call it
vanilla isis vanilla isis it's like well
um
it was antifa that just executed a guy
in the street i mean
that sounds a little isis-y if you ask
yeah and the the
the horrifying thing about this i was
thinking about it are there are there
any stories of trump supporters
just like a dude in a magazine like
walking up and executing a leftist or
anything like that
no or even no and you know how i know
because that would be front page
international news
for a month if that happened such a
thing has not happened
and it won't happen i don't i pray not
you know i'm really hoping nothing like
that happens because now i'm terrified
of what happens if some
if a group like uh patriot prayer
decides to try to
retaliate i'm worried or if patriot
prayer doesn't return
like okay if patriot prayer decides to
do a march yeah that's it
that's the then you're going to have all
of these democrat operatives
and the press sitting in their chairs
salivating like
you step on a twig and we are going to
write a front page story claiming you
did horrifying things
tim they're having one on the 26th oh
yes that's a bad idea yeah here's the
challenge
do we tell them you are not like do not
go out and express yourselves on the
first amendment i i know
that makes me mad and that's what the
left wants they can create this
circumstance
the i should say the far left these
extremists they want to create a
circumstance where the right knows that
if they step out of line in any way and
they've come out
they'll start the fight and the press
will defend the extremists this is kind
of clever
because you're not actually saying you
cannot come out you're not actually
saying you may not speak
you are telling them that if they do
they'll suffer for it
but they're not actually they're not
overtly saying it's all very covert and
of course because the media has their
back it's going to work that's true
that's tough
you know like uh again i want to be
careful when i say this
i think it was mike cernovich who said
stay home make money vote or whatever i
don't want to
miss a tribute quote to somebody who
didn't say it but i i someone tweeted it
i think it was mike
the point is man that's tough
uh we all have rights you know we can go
out and wave little flags if we want to
and getting attacked by antifa that's
messed up that the media does this
right that's why i rag on them so much
like this whole episode's like me ragged
on the media well yeah of course because
the media controls what people think of
the world way more than they should
we give them far more power and far more
credit than we should well
so they need to be held to account i i
was thinking something earlier today you
know that actually gave me hope
i think i think the media class on the
verge of collapse entirely
even though we're seeing ratings go up
and everything we were joking just a
moment ago about
if trump loses like they're wiped out
right
and i feel like that what we're seeing
right now even with tucker carlson
is trump is inflating all media
viewership
i think everything drops dramatically if
trump loses
but internet shows particularly like
this one
are gonna survive and flourish i was
thinking about something
and i'm gonna uh i mentioned i think i
mentioned this last week but i was
thinking about it again today especially
with donald trump tweeting
liking my tweet why didn't anybody
ask me anything why didn't they talk to
you about it no one says
anything about it something really funny
happened so apparently
uh some people on wikipedia have been
complaining my career stops at 2017.
the media just stopped talking about me
why is that i don't know
i think it's funny my well i have a
general idea
and i know this may seem like i rarely
talk about myself this directly but
in the past month with youtube podcast
and facebook it's over
100 million views across all of my my
content
and uh it's like you know three hours
and 40 minutes a day of content
so it's it's kind of it's it's these are
big numbers
apparently i'm getting hit by people you
know trump is liking my tweet
i'm getting a bunch of attention and the
media completely ignores
everything about me in fact somebody
tweeted about me
saying something critical and some other
leftist replied
who like no one cares who he is there
was a really funny tweet
about a year ago or so where some
leftist journalists tweeted something
like
whatever happened to that tim pool guy
it's so sad he was getting six figures
working for these companies and now he's
got like a crappy little patreon getting
like a thousand bucks
because i don't use patreon right but
just like sitting there and i'm just
like it's really amazing
and i think this you know when i reflect
on myself in my work is a really good
example of how broken the media is and
why it's going to die
it's simple if they had any idea what
was actually going on
outside of their mainstream bubble their
beltway bubble the kind of conversations
people were having
then they'd be like what's up with this
dude who's getting 100 million views
a month per month who just got a like
from the president instead
all these outlets that were talking
about trump liking my tweet we're saying
things like
trump liked to tweet you know from a
user saying
kyle written us a good example of why i
voted decided to vote for the president
they didn't stop to be like this guy's
got 650 000 followers and like who is he
and look into me none of that
nothing at all so does this make you
feel like super famous or super stealthy
or kind of annoyed
neither it makes me feel like there's
two realities happening
and it's true like you look at cnn and
man do they have no idea what's going on
but how could it be
that you know like right now fifty two
thousand five hundred and forty one
people watching live you guys are
awesome by the way thanks guys
are watching live and you know having
conversations talking about all this
and they have no idea it's happening
this is this is it i don't think there
is a silent majority no i think there's
there like there's there's a silent
group of people that are scared to speak
up
sure but i think people are speaking up
i think the mainstream media just
is like there there's like it is a
circle of people staring at each other's
butts
and they're like it's like yo we're over
here like are you watching what's
happening
your industry is collapsing so i guess
the way i put it is
the new york times subscriber base is
going up while every other news
organization is collapsing
giving this false idea to these
journalists that they're doing better
when they're actually going down the
drain if they had any idea the
conversations that were happening
outside of the beltway bubble among
moderate disaffected liberals the
politically homeless and conservatives
you mean everyone normal people they'd
be writing they'd be writing a lot more
about this phenomenon
i had someone comment on a post of mine
earlier
about walk away and they were like it's
not real a lefty guy he's like it's not
real people aren't walking away there's
no real data on it
and i was like did you see all the
c-span phone calls
and his response was you know he's like
that's not real data those are anecdotes
it means nothing and i mentioned axios
actually wrote an article about this
saying that republicans are closing the
gap
with registered voters with democrats
over registered voters
and it's not because they're registering
new voters it's it's two big reasons
this is according to axios
people are leaving the democratic party
or they're switching parties
which is giving republicans a boost and
narrowing the gap between the two
parties
i think that proves there is data this
is from cook political uh analysis or
whatever
walkaway is a real phenomenon i think
the media is a little bit like inspector
cluseau and the pink panther
who is really bumbling and i feel like
they're staring with their little
um magnifying glass they're looking for
clues and they're looking in a dark
corner and everyone's behind them and
they're like
what are they doing we're right here
they're like there's no one here you
guys are crazy i don't know what you
guys are talking about there's no silent
majority
i think we're getting to the point and i
you know when you see
brian stelter on cnn and he says
something and you're just like
dude do you have google like what is
this because they all
they all get their news from twitter and
they'll follow each other on twitter and
there have been
progressive journalism professors who
said people have an unhealthy twitter
obsession and these journalists need to
get off of it i remember when there was
a big trend
where i i think it was buzzfeed i'm not
sure they ordered their stuff oh no it
was like outline or something
or dateline i don't remember they
ordered their staff to not use twitter
for a week
to like actually do journalism
you put this look on your face wow yeah
yeah i don't know what happened with it
no
i don't remember i don't know but it
reminds me uh
a bit of what the ryan long comedy
sketch earlier yeah so if you haven't
seen it you definitely got to see ryan
long's comedy sketch
but he in it he says there's like one
guy
stephen king and who else i don't know
they're not on twitter anymore what am i
supposed to do
yeah what am i supposed to do come up
with an article on thin air
and the other guy is like is there a
template for like what people used to do
dude ryan nails a bunch of stuff he's
like
what are these people gonna do after
trump's gone and on our show he was
talking about how they were gonna like
pack it up in a suitcase and just walk
out into the ocean i was like
yeah what are they supposed to do slowly
into the sunset and just walk
under the water and they're into the
water and they're gone i don't know
dude it's so weird because i look you
know
people have said the similar things to
me clearly i just rag on democrats all
the time right therefore
once the political battle is over what
am i going to talk about and i'm like
i'm going to go back talking about the
exact thing i was talking about because
i was making content for the last
several years
i have a video about cultural issues i
have a video uh
like i'm pretty sure it's still this way
on my main channel tim cast
that the default video is me talking
about jordan peterson and cultural
issues i love them nothing to do with
politics
but politics became like the top-tier
pop culture
and so i certainly jumped in the fray i
think
we might we'll see a couple things if
trump leaves
there's of good likelihood they won't
stop doing what they do
they'll just replace trump's name with
something similar
for sure they'll they'll find something
they'll lie
i mean you know maybe maybe i should
take that back
i think they're already squeezing like
you know it's
it's you know what is extra virgin olive
oil is when they like get the first
fresh drop and then yeah i know that's
extra extra isn't it yeah
basically you got a dry withered husk of
an olive and they're like pounding with
a mat like give me
something there's there's better better
way to put it they're scraping of the
bottle
they're scraping the bottom of the
barrel so hard they're pulling up wood
chips people start telling me oh man i'm
seeing a bunch of wood chips lately and
i was like
i know right when they write a story
like vox did
where they said something like what did
they say
40 million americans have alt-right
ideas or something yeah yeah you google
that can you go with that
something like that it's clearly not
true
and they're just like well uh white
nationalists drink water and
you know 40 million americans prefer
water therefore
you find it 11 million americans think
like alt-right
yeah yeah yeah so this is actually from
a little while ago but they're saying
that millions and millions of white
americans are just thinking on
on the same uh-huh that's right because
they like
cats yes apparently that's
that's literally the game they're
playing they're like well the white
nationalists believe that we should have
strong borders therefore
these people think like them dude i have
no patience for that nonsense because it
is possible to have
so what i notice a lot is just a tiny
little grain of truth at the bottom of
everything
and you can go the wrong way with it
like white nationalists or you can be
sane and reasonable about it like a
normal person but the fact that there is
a
common grain of truth they just run wild
with it and it's
yeah nonsense it's getting to the point
where
it's really difficult to actually cover
anything
so for instance there there have been
several stories that i know to be true
and have fact checked but newsguard
the third party faction source will give
it like no this is a bad source
and then you'll get actually here's a
really good example take a look at the
story from the milwaukee journal
sentinel it's one of the first stories
we highlighted oh yeah
trump mischaracterizes kenosha protest
shootings defends rittenhouse okay
we got three journalists on this one
claiming
that because trump said rittenhouse was
attacked and he may have been killed
he's mischaracterizing it i mean that's
an opinion
yeah does it say opinion on here it does
not it says elections
nope it doesn't say an opinion anywhere
so this is an opinion story
whether or not he mischaracterizes
they're asserting as a fact well of
course
newsguard says the only strike they get
is for not disclosing financing
not failing to differentiate fact from
opinion that's fine
yeah it looks fine now to be fair i
guess they can argue it was just one
time they did this
media matters for america which is
rights writes conspiracy theories and
lies all day is green
it's like good to go seriously yeah so
we're we're coming to a point where
this this is the point i'm trying to
make okay so look i wasn't trying to
toot my own horn when i was talking
about my viewership the point i'm trying
to make is
if people on wikipedia are saying things
like
tim pool's career stopped at 2017 and
there's no new information about him at
all on anything he's done
yet like since he left fusion how do we
update this
and like apparently people are saying
things about i recently came out support
of trump therefore they should add it
and they're like there's no articles
about this
nobody cares i love it could you imagine
what would like remember
remember when joe rogan said he would
rather vote for trump over biden not
even committed
right and it was like every paper ever
wrote about it yes they are
articles about that yeah it's so weird
you know you know why i think because
these people still like they use itunes
so when they open the app they see joe
rogan
so they know it right but they're not
attuned to what's going on with the
internet and regular people and where
they're consuming news in digital ways
so they have no idea that conversations
like this happen every single day
to i think what we're at what's with
three to three to 3.5 million viewers
per day
across across all my content and the
media isn't talking about it
and that that is kind of a self uh
self-fulfilling prophecy because
i think to them if an article is not
written about something that happens
it didn't happen which is so really
interesting the best part
i tweeted this oh actually maybe i
didn't tweet it maybe i was like about
to and i deleted it
how is wikipedia supposed to function as
an encyclopedia
if the only criteria for for uh
recording important historical
information is that some 22 year old
you know college grad who makes 30
thousand a year has to blog about it
that's a great question certainly it is
of merit
that you know like the work i do and
over the past several years but the
journalists don't
know what's happening so again i'm not
trying to humble brag or anything
i mean sincerely the point i'm trying to
bring up is
that there's a substantial audience here
the media has no idea it's happening
while their ship is sinking
we're all on a ship sailing towards
golden shores
and and rainbows and you know people are
having pina colada and they're singing
and their ship is headed towards the
waterfall and they're going full speed
ahead i think there's land that way and
we're like what are they doing
they're going the wrong way it's like
blockbuster video man
yeah netflix yeah well they've
simultaneously gotten bigger and bigger
heads as they've engaged on social media
and gotten more and more followers
at the same time their quality is
decreasing as they're outsourcing and
they forget
you know how to google things and how to
research things and how to actually do
investigative journalism like the guy
who did the piece for the new york times
i think it was christian whatever his
last name was
that was impressive i was like he
actually he used to work for um
sorry he used to work for bellingcat and
he actually did investigative journalism
so he actually knows what it's like to
get out
to do research well i mean the research
yeah that's good they hired him right
and now he's got a factual piece of
video like i looked at all the videos
too i saw similar things
and i saw some journalists bring up
these things but so long as you have
many of these underpaid
low-quality fake news what do what do we
call them what's called activists yeah
then you're going to get bad information
they're basically like interns kind of
because you're like saying like the 22
year old who writes about
brad pitt's junk for you know thousand
dollars a year like
that's that's no no no no no not not the
intern not the internet i got ten bucks
an hour
okay okay then just activists well they
um they lower the quality at the same
time the journalists are getting to feel
more and more important because they
have
fake followers on social media because
they reply to trump
and it's like yeah something's wrong
there that's a bubble that's gotta burst
more to each other
you know i notice this too they prop up
their friends to give them followings
and that's one of the issues i think one
of the easiest ways to explain it
actually
if you have one person and they have a
hundred thousand followers
and that one person says hey everybody
follow jim right
then jim gets 60 000 followers then jim
says hey everybody follow bill and then
bill gets 40 000 followers
that's still part of the same group of a
hundred thousand from the first
journalist
yeah that's something that i think about
i'm like if someone recommends me
followers i'm not really getting new
followers i'm just we're just kind of
sharing followers exactly
like that's not really an improvement i
don't really so this is actually a
clever
tactic that uh i won't name the business
but uh
tip what's this model so what you can do
is you can duplicate your follower
account for advertisers
by creating new accounts and having
people follow multiple accounts of yours
so you create a twitter account you get
100 000 followers you create a second
account and you say everybody follow me
on this account too
then you can then you can say i have 150
000 followers
they imagine 150 000 people standing
around when in fact it's the same 100
000. but you do that ten times and you
have a network now and you say our
network has
over a million followers and it's
actually the same hundred thousand
just following a bunch of different
accounts i mean it's clever
it's not technically uh a lie but it's
not it's not completely honest
so if you want to lead people to assume
things anyway the point i'm bringing up
is
these journalists probably have a much
smaller user base than they realize
but they see all these journals all
these followers and think that they're
big when in reality it's like
you know smaller group between them
maybe not maybe
you know it's a larger group but i think
that still is a big plays a big role in
this well i think that's part of having
a bubble in the first place
is following the same journalists and
having the same ideas and kicking the
same things around and retweeting to the
same people
and getting those you know retweets and
comments and everything it's just
oh it's how do you tiresome how you
break people out of this
bubble is this the hardest question i
guess you gotta pop it
no you can't so uh like we we
we've really dived into a lot of the
kyle rittenhouse stuff today and like
trump's answers
there's nothing i could say to my
progressive sjw friends
to convince them that they're wrong
literally nothing
i could send them a video and be like
here's him being attacked and they go i
don't care
i i don't know what to do about that
it's ignorance and apathy
they don't care and they don't know and
how are you supposed to change whether
someone cares about something
you know carlin borisenko i found her
name right right yeah carlin
yeah count your name we're trying yeah
uh she tweeted
something like i thought tim cass was
being hyperbolic when he talked about
civil war
after seeing what's what's it rep val
demings i think her name was say this is
just what happens you know the guy gets
shot in portland part and parcel baby
yeah i may as well just pull the city
con that she was like i guess
something paraphrasing basically that
she thought i was being hyperbolic and
it turns out
i probably wasn't when uh a year ago
one year ago i had some people over to
my house some video producers
and they were talking to me about
potential projects and
you know what they wanted to focus on
and i told them
here's what's going to happen in the
next year and here's what you need to
understand
and i'm not kidding when i say i
predicted the blm riots
100 they didn't believe me
they were like that's ridiculous that's
crazy amazing and but but my prediction
was based on the fact that it already
happened in 2013
2014 2015 i wasn't just making up random
things like ooh and then riots will
happen
over racial issues ooh you're looking at
your crystal ball again i was like this
is what's going to happen next it's
going to be crazy
and i'm like it's going to get bad
people are going to die and they're like
this is nuts and i'm like
it's going to be some kind of civil war
i don't call whatever you want it's not
going to be the way we imagine civil war
but
i don't know what else you call it
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time